hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar not your typical flow
cytometry panel design webinar a toolkit
for selecting antibodies with the
complete panel and mind i am michelle
Astron of labyrinth and I'll be your
moderator for today's events today's
educational web seminar is presented by
blab route the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration sponsored by
best Ning culture life sciences learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.flexsim.com let's get started you
can post questions to the speaker during
the presentation while they're fresh in
your minds to do so simply type them
into the drop down box located on the
far left of your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
questions will be answered after the
presentation to enlarge the slide window
click on the arrows at the top right
hand corner of the presentation window
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing a presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing it into
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen I now present
today's speakers Maria Gentilly and
Michael Kaczynski both senior marketing
managers at Beckman culture of Life
Sciences to learn more about our
speakers please visit the speaker tab at
the top of the presentation window Maria
and Michael you may now begin your
presentation
Thank You Michelle for that kind
introduction Michael and I are really
happy to be here to talk together today
and we'd like to also thank the audience
for being here we've been working on
this collaboration for a while and we're
really enjoying the idea that we can
bring concepts together for both
developing panels and the
instrumentations contribution to that so
you know here we are today and we'd like
to really focus on you know why isn't
why it isn't always advantageous who's
the brightest eyes for every marker in a
panel how do you then incorporate the
instrument characteristics into your
panel design and then you know also
demonstrating how you can apply good
panel design and in a way that helps
both really new new to flow cytometry
users as well as advanced users and how
it makes it easier for you then to
communicate how you've made decisions on
how you put your panel together and then
also learning some things about
technology and how the technology really
can influence the decisions that you
make when when developing a multicolor
panel and so
with that Michael I think I'm going to
hand it over to you I thank you Maria as
you already said
today we really want to convey a very
comprehensive view on what you would
consider then when building a panel so
really looking at the whole system that
we want to optimize not only picking
several features and work on those but
really really considering the complete
system and of course the fluorochromes
are important here so let's start with
the floral Chrome's and look at their
brightness but also considering what
else is a characteristic of through
Chrome for instance they spill over so
what we see here in this scheme is a
relatively limited selection of dyes
that also will be subject to our
examples during the next slides
as we go from left to right here in this
picture we will see that the price the
dyes that have been ranked here have an
increasing relative brightness so from
the very left for instance that we see
under violet laser chrome Orange we have
a dye that you typically would use only
for antigens that are very densely
expressed and as we go to the very
extreme right you'll find PE which is
probably the brightest antigen here in
this scheme that could be used with any
antigen it's bright enough also to be
used with antigens that have a very low
expression density of note this ranking
here is really just a qualitative
ranking so there will be differences in
how these dyes are relatively right to
each other if you consider different
clones or different conjugation
chemistry sometimes the formulation of
the antibody may also play a role
so we just have seen that there is a
broad range of brightness between the
eye some really dim dyes to very bright
dyes and the same of course holds two
for antigen densities if this is not a
much more extensive range if I put some
examples here together let's start maybe
with the human T lymphocyte cd4
expression and the lowest role in this
overlay plot very densely expressed
around 150,000 copies per cell and you
see that the characteristic of this
expression is bimodal so will have a
very bright very densely expressed cd4
on a positive population and will have a
negative population if we now go one
roll buff we see a modulated expression
profiles so here we will have events
that have a very dense expression maybe
even beyond what cd4 is but also we will
see events that have an intermediate
expression density as well as events
that have a very low expression density
so this is probably the most challenging
antigen to implement here and we see
during the next slides so I hope I can
show that why that is let's go one line
further where we see a weak expression
density a negative population and a
positive population however we only have
low expression densities here in this
positive population and then even one
further what we labeled here you need to
believe is that you not only have very
low expression densities on a positive
population but you also have a very low
frequency of this event so here you
really need to make sure that you
recover all the events that are in
there's no positive range the example
would be for instance on stem cell-like
T sets memory type that have a very
density of 95 expression on a very small
portion of the T cells own
so let's go back to the city for example
what I've shown here on the left is a
city for string and you may also
remember the diagram orange to be one of
the dimmest in our range of diets the
reside that we get is however just
bright enough so we see all the city for
positive cells and we also see where we
clearly separated the cd4 negative
population on the right you get exactly
the same result when using a very bright
time again you have a separation between
cd4 negative and cd4 positive however
the separation is much more pronounced
than on the left but still the result
that we get is comparable between left
and right but on the right we see also
that the positive population starts to
get broadening as compared to the
negative population so in this channel
on the y-axis 620 nanometers channel we
will see an increase of measurement
error called spreading on this cd4 pe+
population which limits the sensitivity
for an antigen measured in this channel
that we can achieve on the PD positive
population so brighter is not always
better and really have to understand
that brightness is helpful here in this
case we see that Ryder might be in a
disadvantage and it may be advantageous
to have less brightness on the cd4
positive population
so to summarize be just as bright as
needed but the also as dim as possible
it could be a takeaway here from this
picture
so this brings us to the Goldilocks
principle of dive Lighting's we have two
extremes here we have a very dim
expression very weak expression and a
very strong expression in the top of the
slide and you now want to choose a diet
that allows us to have enough
sensitivity so not be too dim for a
weakly expressed antigen but at the same
time once you consider a strongly
expressed antigen we don't want to have
a dye that is too bright because of too
much spill over that might impair the
sensitivity that we can achieve on other
detectives so we really want to balance
that you want don't want to be too dim
have enough sensitivity but also not
being too bright so that we avoid spill
over into other other channels again it
is basically the same message we just as
right as needed but we also as dim as
possible
just fight the right the right intensity
to really meet meet the needs regarding
your antigen just a real-life example
here again you see a cd4 stand on the
x-axis it's well separated for there is
not a lot of distance but we can clearly
understand what the cd4 positive
population is and without any spreading
into the y-axis we can see the
expression of a very dimly or very
weakly expressed antigen so here we have
to make sure that we use a very bright
dye the brightest dye that we have
that's a nice graphic representing the
first principle which is understanding
what expression type you're dealing with
and also balancing that with the right
combination of florrum
yeah let's let's take this now a little
bit harder so we have matched the
antigen density with the dive right
nurse and we have done this considering
the brightness of the dye but also the
spill over that it conveys to other
detectives and here's just an example
what that can mean in real life so we
have 210 color penalty in this picture
in each of them the same antibody clones
were used
however from between left and right
we have swapped the floral assignments
the fulcrum posts and labels of the
antibodies and except for CDX PC 5.5 so
this this antibody that obviously
detects a very weakly expressed antigen
is the same in the panel on the left and
on the right however the results that we
obtained using the same antibiotic shown
here even on the same sample of course
are very different so on the right plot
we can only detect about 1/4 of the
positive events that we can detect on
the left and the reason for that is that
the other florists and labels that are
on the same cells of interest here
impact the resolution that we can obtain
on the PC point 5 channel on the right
while on the Left we have done a very
smart design avoiding these spill over
effects into the PC 5.5 channel so we
can have a very sensitive detection so
what we can take away from this
comparing this to staining is that the
sensitivity of detection for any labeled
antigen is really a function of all the
fruits and labels that defined on the
cell surface
so sensitivity for each antigen will be
determined not only by the fluorescent
label that are used for this antigen but
also by these spectra surrounding the
spectral neighborhood all the other
labels that are also present on the
sensor same cell surface and remove are
larger with the biological point of view
this just means the antigen expression
pattern will be very important regarding
the sensitivity that we can achieve for
the given antigen so let's try to put
this a little bit together we have seen
turtle chrome characteristics brightness
spill over we now want to take the
biology also on board to put this
together and furthermore of course we
will look into the way that a certain
instrument that a certain detector will
detect with you how a certain detection
system will detect fluorescence signal
and how it will process that because
this also will have an influence and how
we think panel design and it will
especially be important for the
stringency that we have to apply when
designing panels
so while we want to talk about the
biology in a certain antibody panel that
we want to apply it is very efficient to
use antigen Crees like we see here on
the right in an antigen tree we can
implement all the relationships between
the antigens and alter by color coding
this here we can show the expression
profiles that are associated with these
antigens as we see on the right I
remember we have used this depiction
couple of slides earlier already so for
instance a green antigen in the antigen
tree is a densely expressed by modal
antigens where for instance a purple one
is a weakly expressed antigen so to
understand this this tree and what
information is in fact this tree maybe
we start with looking at the
parent-child relationship
so a child antigen what else already
always be co-expressed together with its
corresponding parent antigen whereas a
parent antigen may well be expressed
that out this child antigen could be
expressed with other child antigens also
giving rise to various subpopulations a
common example for this situation is the
expression of the cd3 antigen and
principal t-cell antigen and then you
might imagine a second antigen named CDX
here it could be a modulated antigen
exclusively expressed by t-cells
furthermore let's consider two dyes for
example here like EC dpe Texas red dye
with an intermediate brightness and a
very bright die TC 5.5 CD 3 as an
additional information here causes spill
over spreading into the detector where
we would want to detect TC 5.5 Y vice
versa this is not the case and this is
indicated here by the gray triangle that
you see along the quadrant and along the
y axis so following our idea of matching
antigen density with Rover chrome
brightness we have chosen here on the
left the ECD dye to detect CDs free so
the intermediate brightness and the vary
by PC 5.5 we have chosen to use the
decoy expressed antigen on the
co-expressed modulated antigen here in
this case and what we see in the gray
triangle that you would find dots in
there that are gray added are green but
also other dots that are red so this
indicates here that we have a certain
range on the log scale where we would
not be
where we would not be able to
distinguish between green dots that make
part of the negative population and just
lie in this range of the scale because
of the measurement error the spillover
spreading of ECD into pc 5.5 but also we
see red dots in there that represent
events that have a specifically positive
expression of CX but it will not being
able to distinguish between those so
what we end up with here is a loss of
sensitivity for those no expressions on
the right we have swapped the fuel
crumbs now and now we have chosen the
stronger dye for the lineage antigen and
the co-expressed i for the intermediate
brightness antigen forbidding
intermediate brightness top however what
we also see that there is no spreading
from the pc 5.5 dye into the ECD channel
and this allows us to have a very
clearly resolved cutoff of negative vs.
dim positive and so we will be able to
detect all those CDX positive cells that
have a very low antigen expression
density which gives us overall the
better sensitivity as compared to the
case on the left so the takeaway message
here is that spill over from parent
antigen into child antigen should be
avoided even this may this may override
other words like the antigen density
through chrome brightness rule on the
right we have made sure that the spill
over here only occurs from the child
antigen into the parent antigen and this
gives us the possibility to have much
better resolution and a much better
sensitivity then seen on the left
so what does this mean in real life
that's look into a real example on the
Left we again with the cd4 strain we
have considered floors only so the PE
would cause a lot of spreading in the
ECD channel and people may be concern
not to have PE and ECD labels that could
occur on the same cell I have on the
right we have taken the biology author
into account and using here a B cell
lineage marking cd19 and a co-expressed
marker that is the immunoglobulin light
chain lambda that you will find
exclusively on the B cells arranging
this now in a way that the parent
antigen would fit in the panel that
receives the spillover from PE we see
that there is no spreading problem
occurring we don't have PE positive
events here that would not carry the B
cell antigen and this allows us to use
this combination without any impact on
our data quality so why would we
consider that well of course when we use
a lot of fluorochromes in our panel
really use every channel maybe on our
instrument then we will use dyes that
have spillover so we have to make sure
that we deal very economically with
those pairs they do not have any
spillover at all and so you would want
to identify biological expression
patterns that would tolerate the use of
fluorochromes that have a strong
spillover so mmm
this into our antigen tree we for
instance could use these arrows here a
green arrow that indicates that
spillover would be allowed and a red
arrow that you should avoid spilled over
when designing the pellet the arrows
that are in this tree now would indicate
the interaction between different
hierarchies in the in the tree so maybe
we'll have a look at the parent to
understand how that works into the
parents are pointing into the parent
antigen you now have a green arrow so
this will tell us that the parent can
well receive spillover without and the
impact on data quality but at the same
time they have a red arrow that points
out of the parent down to the next
hierarchy and this according to our
parent-child concept would say please
avoid spillover from this parent into
its child antigens
that makes it really clear I really like
this graphical representation and it
really helps when you know understanding
that comes it's the principle force what
you can allow to spill over and what is
to be avoided and so when moving up the
tree
Phil over is allowed and moving down the
tree in levels of the hierarchy to avoid
spillover
netiquette that is a very crisp way of
saying it just taking of this going down
and going up principal and how this is
corresponding to this bill over
spreading allowance or avoidance rules
so now let's think what how we can think
about spillover spreading effects that
may occur in the same within the same
hair routine not only between
laboratories and to do that I think it's
a good model to have a look at modulated
antigens that have
cells that have a very low billet cells
that have a very low expression density
of the antigen and cells that have a
very high expression as density of the
antigen alike what we see here are plot
the plot on the left and on the right
are taken from the same data set
actually we are looking at exactly the
same T cells here and we look at the
expression of ccr7 on these YX is CD 197
and we have Co expressed checkpoint
markers here and all of these antigens
have a modulated expression profile on
the Left we have made sure that the dyes
that you are using to detect those
antigens do not cause spillover
spreading in each other's detectors and
the result is that independently here
from let's say the ccr7 expression
density it can detect CDs 160 16 3 with
the same sensitivity so regardless of a
strong or a weak ccr7 expression there
is an independent sensitivity for Tim 3
is independent from that and in contrast
to that you see on the right what often
is referred to as a spreading trumpet so
here pc 5.5 causes a strong spill over
into the pc 7 channel where we want to
detect the co-expressed lagg-3 or CD 223
antigen and as the ccr7
expression which freezes also the TC 5.5
signal of course gets stronger and this
means that we have more spill over for a
high pc 5.5 signal into the pc 7 channel
this translates to a larger spreading
effect and finally in turn this limits
the sensitivity that we can achieve for
lengthy expression on those cells that
have a high ccr7 expression so that is
definitely a situation that we want to
avoid we want to be on the left
where these two antigens can be detected
with a high sensitivity independent of
each other's expression them going back
to our scheme we now again will
implement within a certain hierarchy of
expression the green and red arrows and
you see that these errors have been
tilted a bit not to indicate that we are
not talking between hierarchies here but
within the same hierarchy let's have a
look at a certain element of the
hierarchy to understand how this works
now the sec child a child a has an arrow
going out of of the antigen so we want
to avoid spill over from child a to
other members of the same helper high
repeat level whereas the green arrow
indicates that child a could tolerate
spill over and that is based on the
nature of the expression profile that we
see on the Left we have a very strong
bimodal expression so if we would have a
spreading effect for the negative
population this will not keep us from
detecting the positive population in
contrast the purple proper color of
child D indicates that we have a weak
expression here so the weak expression
allows as indicated by the green arrow
to exert spill over to other antigens of
the same hierarchy as the the sheer
amount of the spill over will be very
little so we can be confident that this
will not impact the sensitivity however
child E is very weakly expressed so we
must sure must make sure that spill over
into the channel where we want to detect
charge D must be avoided so we will not
put the detection of those low expresses
at risk so we see other elements also
here in this antigen tree well we have
an exclusion and also a positive
correlation
let's have a look into what that means
for penalty dice so we can start
considering floors only on the left
where we have to strongly expressed
antigens and we have made sure to deform
to the eighth in a t-cell gate here and
we have make sure that the user poems
that have very little spillover into
each other so this gives us a very nice
picture but you need to be really
economic with those kind of your own
paths that you have no spillover at the
same time have a relative good rightness
we don't have an endless number of those
pairings so we may again also consider
the biology in order to find some
modified to identify the situations that
would also allow us to use google
chrome's that have a higher spillover
than seeing on the list and that is
exactly what is done on the right using
CD for a PC and cd8
a PC Alexa 700 so these are two
fluorochromes that sit very whose
emission characteristics have
considerable spill over into each
other's detectors we also see by the
spreading of the positive populations
however we also see that the
discrimination limit of interest are not
in a range where they would be affected
by this spill over so again we can
detect cd4 and cd8 in with the same
sensitivity on the left
despite we are using through proms that
have a very strong spreading effect on
each other so we can allow spillover
between excluding antigens it will not
cause any problems forms
and this also holds true for a situation
expression situation that basically is
the opposite of what we just have seen
before here we have two antigens that
are not excluding each other but two
antigens that always occur together on
the same cell on the left again just
considering the fluid from the fruit on
characteristics we have chosen two for
problems that have no spillover or very
little low spillover spreading effect
regarding each other detectives and on
the right we have in contrast to that
used pure chromes that have considerable
spreading effects and because here we
again have made use of the biology so we
know that those two antigens left very
similar like on the left always occur
together on same cell for surface the
only difference is that you may see
between cells and between certain
samples is that expression densities may
be modulated so on this is indicated
here by this discrimination of interest
dotted lines which clearly indicates
that you might just be interested here
in a loss of a certain density of
expression but not in discriminating
between negative and dim or weakly
positive events so like with the
exclusion in the situation where we have
a positive correlation between antigens
we can also allow to use fluorochromes
that have considerable spillover into
each other's detectives
so adding this to an certain scene now
with the exclusion pairing and the
positive correlation pairing you can add
an arrow here two-headed arrow that is
all green allowing indicating that there
is mutual spillover allowed for this
kind of expression situation
so putting the
together now we see the biology on the
upper right here where we see how the
biology influences our rule of panel
design regarding the spillover and the
floral chrome brightness we have the
ranking of the fluorochromes on the
lower right and now on the left foot
comes on top of it is what we call the
spreading matrix here and they're
spreading matrix you would see that each
detector is represented by a row and
each color that we want to use on this
detectors is represented by a column and
as we now go down a column we would see
how a certain flow from emission would
cause spreading effect on these
detectors that are present represented
by the roll and you see the legend below
so pale blue would mean there's no
spreading effect and it was would be
scared to dark red that we would see
very strong spreading effect so how does
this tree element now can be used
together let's have a look at some
examples here for instance the parent
entity so the parent entity as you see
in the spreading matrix on the right has
been put into the chrome orange column
and in the chrome orange column you see
mainly blue fields and some have a light
shade of red however in those fields
whether we have a light shade of red
there are no antigens except for age a
modulated antigen where we can expect a
slight increase of spreading but not
dramatically so we have been using a
bright boy that has little impact on the
other antigens for the parent and let's
take another it's example to show also
the exclusion principle child a and
shall see and not expressed together so
we see them in the left on two places
Alexa 700 and avexir 752 columns that
represent dyes that have a strong spill
over to each other you can
see how a and C share side of a dark red
feared so a would cause a lot of
spreading in the channel where C is
detected however as a and C do not occur
on the same cell surface we can make use
of this biological feature in order to
use a pairing of dyes that may not be
used in case where we would see Co
expression of the dyes that is how how
this principle can work when we consider
all features that we have touched upon
but I think it is important also to
understand a little bit better what is
behind the spreading matrix and for this
I would like to hand over to you Maria
thanks Michael I really enjoy you know
seeing all of these concepts come
together in a graphical way what great
tools right for when you're designing a
panel and you can you can actually
understand the instrument and how the
instrument can either help you or things
that you may need to accommodate for and
so let's get then moving into that topic
of what the instrument contributes and
some considerations that you can make
that might help you with your with your
panel design
so the next part of the talk then we're
going to focus on the instrumentation
and the how instruments are responsible
for managing light and also where the
software is important for not only
controlling the instrument but for for
providing tools that can also facilitate
your workflow and traditionally I think
it's okay to say that we've had to think
about our instrumentation as what
constraints does it put upon my
experimental design
I think the newer technology and
specifically we're going to talk about
the side effects I think it's fair to
say that you can ask a different
question now you can ask what can my
instrument do for me to help to make my
life easier help to make my panel design
maybe a little bit simpler because as
you could see from the concepts that
Michael presented there's a lot of
principles to consider and there's a lot
of interplay between those principles
and so the side effects actually was
designed specifically to tackle the
challenges that the instrumentation
might play in those those considerations
and so side effects was designed to
reduce noise and manage light and we're
going to look at how how that works
so these are the two principles that I'd
like to focus on first of all the
compensation doesn't cause data
spreading it only reveals it and the
measurement error is the root of all of
the data spreading so it's the root
cause of data spreading and so let's
look at how instrument design can
influence influence these two principles
of all we're going to focus on
instrumentation light management and
software and how does how does the
instrumentation contribute to reducing
the measurement error which in turn
reduces data spreading so the three
components on the site of flex that
contribute to reducing measurement error
so the smart decisions made about the
components and the design of the
components that are on the
instrumentation one the detectors that
were chosen are Evelyn's photo diodes
which are known for having less noise so
being being having less measurement
error and part of that is because
there's a small area upon which the
signal is detected number two are the
optics so the optics are designed
specifically to focus light better and
reduce optical noise and so it's a
composite objective that accomplishes
this thirdly we need to think about the
electronic noise so there are controls
put into place
to help to help to reduce the noise from
the digitization of the signals and
hence that is that is the way that
signal is then translated into the way
we visualize it within the software
so a bringing that into like a data
visualization carradine we can look at
two different types of instruments right
so we have on the left an instrument
that's PMT based and on the right and
instruments that that is a PD bass but
specifically the sight of flex so using
that example again of cd4 labeled with
te we can see on the PMT based detection
system the spreading that is a result of
the measurement error when the signal
gets very bright and you can see that
spill over into adjacent channels and
then on the on the right side of the
slide here we're looking at that same
antibody flora chrome compensate
combination but this time detected on a
different instrument design okay so
there's an APD based detection there's
also other controls in place that help
to reduce the spreading
it's important to quickly touch upon
what this again means ready for the
panel design on the Left we have a
situation with this considerable
substantial spreading that limits the
biological combinations that we can put
here so for instance in this case the
detector that is affected by spreading
would have to carry a parent antigen or
the detector rather die that exerts this
spreading to the to the other detector
would have to be a dim expression while
on the right on the right where we don't
have this restriction there is no mo
spreading we basically are very very
free and what we want to put it which
co-expression markers or which other
markers would go there so it gives us a
lot of flexibility and there's very
little restriction on the biological
relationship of the antigen that can be
detected in such a setting I think that
is really important to understand in
order to link back how the instrument
would really influence your ideas and
thoughts about how to design the panel
exactly that's such a good example
Thanks
so then you know what else we mentioned
so we talked about measurement error and
controlling that and how that might help
to influence the decisions that you make
about your panel design now let's look
at sensitivity so instrumentation is
also responsible for allowing detection
of dimly expressed and some of those
modulated majul ated expressed markers
as well as the ones that are so dim that
may be in so infrequent that you're
really not sure that they're really even
there so what can an instrument do to
help out with those situations so the
three components that I'm going to focus
on next are the excitation optics
emission optics and detectors again the
excitation optics basically focusing on
the flow cell the flow cell was designed
with the beam shaping optic integrated
and so we can think about every time the
light has to move through or across a
surface it would be transmitted from one
component to another it's an opportunity
for light to get lost and for us to lose
efficiency in that light transmission
and so integrating the beam shaping
optic into the flow cell reduces that
that opportunity right so it helps with
the efficiency of the movement of light
from your sample out of the flow cell
onto the optics and so moving on to the
emission optics then we can see the
fiber delivering the light onto the
wavelength division multiplexer which is
designed specifically and also to
increase the efficiency of that light
movement and so as the light moves
through a bandpass filter onto its
detector the rest of that light is
reflected back onto a mirror and so that
once again there's no dichroic s--
therefore there's that minimum you know
minimizing the risk of light loss that
would happen in the presence of that
type of transmission of light and we can
also think of this as all of the light
gets you know this system is designed to
collect all of the light and then the
software is smart in order to manage the
interpretation of that light movement
and then once again we've got highly
efficient high quantum efficiency
photodiode
detectors on board which are known for
their efficiency across a broad range of
emission wavelengths and also have a
really good conversion of photons to
digital digital signals
and the way we usually measure this or a
traditional way of measuring this is by
using a multi intensity bead mixture
that can display different different the
resolution the resolution power across
the different channels of an instrument
so what we're looking at here are seven
different laser options that are
available on the side of flex platform
so on the LX you have an option for a
total of six lasers and you can choose
between the UV or the NIR UV as well as
having an infrared laser on board and so
for the six of seven lasers were
demonstrating the resolving power using
the rainbow calibration particles from
Spirit X and this is a commonly used way
of of you know calibrating as well as
aligning or optimizing the alignment of
instrumentation so we can see and most
of the channels we've got all eight
Peaks resolved and many of them are
baseline resolved so really good
resolution power as display using multi
peak beads and for the IR laser what's
shown here is a multi intensity bead
mixture of I are exciting and emitting
particles from spirit Eck as well this
is a really nice controlled way of
looking at the resolving power of
instrumentation but what's really
important is the biology right so how
does the instrumentation contribute to
the power you have to resolve these
dimly expressed and modulated signals
and the balancing act that you've got to
think about when you're putting a
complex panel together I'd like to look
at this data and say hmm things look
pretty tight right I've got some really
nicely tightly distributed populations
where it's not difficult to decide where
to draw my gates so from a data you know
from an overview data analysis
perspective I can look at this and say i
think you know i'm i can draw gates
pretty easily and make my biological
interpretations quite easily let's focus
on a few of these plots and I'm going to
ask Michael to talk us through the the
biology here and the significance yeah
thank you Mario so I'm really not the
the bleach-based person so I really like
that the we see
biologically samples here under less you
see the buzzer feels very nicely
separated out of the whole crowd of
leukocytes of course there's two aspects
here on one hand the clones being use
the plural problems are really nice but
also the instrument about here for very
crisp and sharp sharp carving out of the
battlefield we see the t-rex in the
middle with a 127 and 25 staining where
I think you can see that these staining
the city 25 high and city 127 population
which is clustering very nicely so again
very good resolution and on the right
here on the IR laser we have the cd14
antigen a very strongly modulated
antigen so I mentioned already earlier
that the modulated antigen might be the
most challenging to implement and here
we have a real isolated possibility
spectrally isolated possibility on the
our laser to have bright signals on the
mono sides without any impact on others
but at the same time they are ir laser
detectors are not subject to spill over
from other laser detectives so you can
also very nicely detect here those dim
expresses great it's such a good example
so let's then continue to talk about
more about the instrumentation light
management and software and how let's
focus a little bit more now on the
software part of things so we discussed
measurement error being reduced how we
have the instrumentation can contribute
to the sensitivity and now we can talk
about how the software might help to
facilitate your workflow I'd like to
introduce a topic about the relationship
between the voltage or gain and the
fluorescence intensity we want to fold a
photomultiplier tube this is a nonlinear
relationship and so it's not easy to
predict and therefore when adjustments
are made to the voltages it's required
that you know experimental design and
settings need to accommodate for that
right it's something you have to
determine empirically and iteratively
and a system that's equipped with
Avalanche photodiodes there's a
potential for the software to make use
of that information right so we've got a
really reproducible manufacturing
process for the semiconductors they're
really well controlled and therefore
they're easy to predict and as well as
they're very linear the response between
the gain and the fluorescence intensity
or the floret the response on that
detector is very linear and so this is
something that the software can be used
to actually predict and facilitate
workflow so let's take a look at that
next
if we are working in the site expert
software controlling a site a flex
instrument we during our experimental
setup can utilize the capability called
gain independent compensation so what
this means is that when you create your
compensation you can you know acquire
the single as much as you're used to
doing and save the matrix or save B
settings or the the files to a
compensation library so then you go to
your experiment right and you import the
compensation into the experiment a
software window a window will pop up in
the software and it'll give you some
options you can import the compensation
matrix and actually recalculate it with
the current gains that you maybe have
been already working with or you can
just import the matrix and the game as
it was acquired so there are new options
that I don't think are customary for the
flow cytometry workflow but these are
these are options that you have
available when working with a site of
Flex and we're going to and what we've
been talking about up until now is the
reason why so the really nice thing is
that you can adjust your gains on the
sample if you need to and the
compensation will automatically adjust
so the next thing we want to show I want
to show you is actually how that works
within the software right so what we're
going to see next is a short video clip
within the the site expert software
where you'll see a compensation matrix
and you'll see a couple of plots and the
plots here one of them the user that's
driving the software is going to access
the game tool from the from the menu
ribbon and then they're going to point
out on the compensation matrix what you
should be focusing on you're going to
actually run the sample and adjust the
gain during that acquisition and what
you'll be able to see is the values and
that compensation matrix adjusting in
real time let's go ahead and play that
video
so the the cursor is now moving pointing
out the compensation matrix and showing
you these values and then once we grab
the gain control tool from the from the
menu sliding it across the plot actually
changes the acquisition setting or the
gain setting and the the compensation
matrix recalculated in real time and
that is basically something that you
have affordable to you within the site
expert software which really is a very
unique powerful tool
and so that is a powerful tool within
the software that is that I'd like to
next demonstrate the utility of by
reviewing with you the workflows for
compensation so I hope so that my
intention to showing this video was to
demonstrate the gain in dependent
compensation in action and now let's
look at how that translates into into
the workflow for generating a
compensation matrix
so this is a traditional workflow what
we normally do is we prepare a series of
tubes that wretch tube is a single
stained control that represents each
color each flora chrome that you've got
present in your panel and you find the
good setting for each one of those
single stained tubes then you acquire
each one of those at the at the settings
that you determined the calculus the
compensation matrix is then calculated
the matrix is then imported into an
experiment and then you'll acquire your
mixed stain sample using the settings
that you would determined for that
compensation matrix you take a look at
the data you assess the data then you
decide in the workflow where that
question mark is this is where we're
deciding am I happy with the data or am
I not happy with the data if I don't
think there's any adjustment needed
we're going to follow the path to
analyzing the data which were you know
we're ready to go but if there is
something that's not quite perfect we
could that we can't just do post
acquisition compensation adjustment for
it something that actually really does
need a gain adjustment for we then need
to go down down the path where we have
to rerun the mix stain sample and make
that voltage adjustment then go back and
reacquire every single one of those
single colored stains at those new
settings recalculate the compensation
matrix and then look at my mixed stain
sample again assess the data and come
back to asking myself am i happy with
that or not and if I'm not happy I've
got to go back through that loop and
continue to follow the loop until I'm
happy or until I'm just happy enough and
I move forward with my experiment so it
can be quite tedious and quite iterative
and the more colors you have in your
path the longer this type this type of
workflow can take
so on the site of flex it's changed
everything really well hasn't changed
everything we've got the beginning where
it's the same where you need to have a
single stained control for each one of
the floors that are represented in your
panel you can calculate the compensation
matrix once you acquire those singles
colored stains at a reasonable voltage
setting and then you know you import
those compensation settings into your
experiment and you can decide at that
point whether or not you want to adopt
the games from your experiment or leave
them the same as what you which you
acquire during your compensation
acquisition but the thing here is that
the software at this point could even
recalculate for you you can then acquire
your mix stain sample assess the data
and make your that decision-making point
now where you're either happy with the
data or not and if you're if you're not
quite happy with the data you can put
your mixed stain sample back on and
during the acquisition adjust the game's
the compensation will recalculate
automatically and you're done you don't
have to go back and reacquire all of the
single colored stain tubes because the
software can accommodate for the smart
design of the instrumentation and it can
utilize that information to simplify the
workflow and the supply gain independent
compensation which makes the workflow
you know much much simpler especially
the more complex situation that you get
into with multicolor panel design
flex platform really is flexible and it
also provides exquisite sensitivity
sensitivity for fluorescence as well as
small particle characterization and
detection in a benchtop analyzer there's
an extensive set of repositionable
bandpass filters that come with each
instrument you can upgrade within a
series by activating additional
detection channels which would be like
you can turn on a laser you can add a
diction additional detector activation
in that in within a series and it's
powered by intuitive software the site
expert software is really powerful and
as well flexible that helps to there's
lots of tools in there that really help
to make your your multicolor panel
design and analysis much simpler and you
can find more information at Beckman
comm forward slash Saito flex
and we've also today talked about some
resources and we provided some resources
in the webinar so in the resources
section you'll be able to find the site
of flex fluorochromes chart that has a
configuration diagrams for each model
within each series and then we've also
provided the poster that demonstrates
the 21 color twenty marker immunity no
typing example that we showed data from
today and additionally a poster from a
couple of years ago at Saito where a 27
marker was demonstrated on a three laser
sight of flex also demonstrating that if
you're using good panel design
incorporating marker stacking and smart
instrumentation you can do deep Amina
food and typing with a simple
configuration as well so I am happy now
to take see if Michaels got any further
comments for us
would like to summarize what we have
been going along here so bright dyes are
not always the best solution you really
have to follow this Goldilocks principle
finding the optimal match of brightness
for the antigen expression that you want
to look at and and we have seen that the
instrument characteristics will be
spreading matrix are also very important
to understand so how sensitive can you
be on a certain channel how susceptible
is a certain channel to spreading when
receiving spillover from other dyes the
biology is really central so on this
this covers the expression profile but
also the relationship between those
antigens that have these specific
expression profiles so I would like to
remind you of organizing the panel in a
tree like in a tree like shape to really
understand best where you can allow to
have spring over where you should avoid
it how do these antigens relate to each
other I think that this is pretty
helpful and then of course I would like
to point at the resource section like my
rear that has done already here you find
many examples that illustrate very well
how you can follow these principles and
how you can achieve powerful panel
solution see how the instrumentation can
help to simplify the decisions you need
to make as sometimes you just have hard
decisions to make
except this so I think Maria we at the
point when we
right I've finished our presentation we
would like to to thank you for your kind
attention and hope it was informative
for you
[Music]
yeah I think we didn't have any
questions we were here now to answer any
questions that you might have yes thank
you
please go ahead
Thank You Maria and Michael for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of the
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
Maria and Michael will answer as many
questions as time permits ok let's get
started the first question is is Dane
independent compensation a new
capability on the side effects oh good
question actually no it's been capable
since the very first release of the
software and the hardware so side
effects has always been capable of being
independent organization and I'm if you
would like more information on that we
can we can definitely help so yeah it's
been there the whole time
great thank you regarding an existing
antibody panel in my lab how could I
check the panel performance and see if I
am missing something due to sub optimal
optimal panel design
I would like to take this mic off so
this is a really really good question so
once you have already something that you
all have got experiences on but maybe
there is something some hidden flaw on
it that you might not have been aware of
so the best way to do that is really for
my part that you look at the single
color staining and see how each of the
single colors influences the background
on each other channels and maybe you
also do FM all controls look at this MMO
controls not only from the angle that
you inspect the channel where you have
left out the die but also look at the
other channels what does leaving out a
certain marker do to the background of
the other channel I think that is a very
effective way to see if there is a
combination of antigens that causes a
lot of sensitivity on a given channel so
please use your ever more controls
looking at each and every channel and
see how different is that as compared to
the complete staining that would help to
see if you're missing something thank
you what guys do you recommend using for
the IR laser
okay I'll take that one so there is the
via chrome 808 that was demonstrated in
the poster the data that we show today
and that is a fixable viability dye and
that can be detected on the 85 40
Channel and then believe that CD 14 was
labeled with Alexa fluor 790 and that
was detected on the 840 20 channels
great thank you
okay next question how can I measure and
compare the performance of different
antibodies against the same antigen both
Michael I would like to take this one I
think that two ways so one way is you
could just do single things and see how
well the separation is between the
positive and the negative part of your
profile this is what typically is
referred to as a signal to noise ratio
that's a good approach however if it
comes to multicolor staining I think
it's better to think about what is
called the staining index so that is not
like the signal-to-noise ratio just
filling the ratio of positives and
negatives for scent intensity here you
would look at the difference so the
Delta of the intensity and you would
divide the Delta by the broadness the
standard deviation of your negative peak
so you can well imagine as you have a
certain separation represented by a
Delta and for sense intensity the
effective separation will be impaired as
the negative population will get broader
and broader due to spreading effects
related to the panel design so this will
really tell you within the application
that you are aiming to to build how is
the separation of the markers and then
you can also compare different positions
of this marker so you use different
fluorochromes on for this marker so you
have different spectral environments
also for detection of of this antigen
and this is how I would compare this
when I really think about the design of
panels think about the stain index
thank you it looks like we have time for
one more question
could you further comment on why
especially antigens with modulated
expression densities can be difficult to
implement into an antibody panel now I
would like to take also this one so
modulated expression refers to a profile
an expression profile that we would see
cells that have a very high expression
density but also we would have cells
with intermediate and also low
expression density and this sets up a
couple of requirements on the one hand
you want to use a die for that that does
not have a large impact on other
channels because we will have very
bright events and we want to avoid with
these wide events cause spreading in the
channel which will make it difficult in
these other channels to detect
co-expressed antigens but at the same
time they have very low expression
densities so the channel for the
detection of the modulated antigen also
should be clean off spill over from
other channels so we have basically
polished requirements at the same time
not to exert spillover but also not to
be receiving spillover from other
antigens that makes it the typical there
is not so much dyes and positions in a
certain set of detective arrays that
fulfill all these requirements
thank you I would like to once again
thank Maria and Michael for their
presentation I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today will be
addressed by the speakers via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank clappers and our sponsor spectrum
culture for today's educational webcast
Robert's will alert via email when it's
available for replay we encourage you to
share that email with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time goodbye